bonsoir bonsoir
je vous remercie de m'accueillir ce soir
et merci de m'avoir invité à participer
à cette conférence
je suis christian gay me j'ai 40 ans je
suis artiste peintre mais je suis plus
connu sous le nom de ces 215 qui est mon
pseudonyme en fait car j'ai je peins
dans la rue je peins ce qu'on appelle du
graffiti ou du street art
je peints au pochoir avec des bombes
aérosols je peins dans la rue je peins
dans des contextes je peins sur des
objets je me déplace je voyage dans des
bidonvilles dans des situations
architectural diverses dont quatre coins
de la planète et j'ai fait de ce hobby
dix ans que je fais ça j'ai fait ce
hobby un métier puisque j'expose par
ailleurs dans des galeries où je
présente des objets sur lequel je peins
j'expose dans des musées j'ai des
oeuvres dans les collections publiques
je travaille pour les institutions je
réalise des commandes pour des
municipalités
voilà j'ai fait en fait de ce
une réalité car le principe en fait de
mon oeuvre c'est la réalité
je travaille à partir de photographies
puisque je fais essentiellement des
portraits des portraits humains des
portraits animaliers et toutes mes
oeuvres sont le plus souvent construites
sur des images réelles à partir de ces
images et ces photographies chez
transforme en pochoir avec ses pots soir
je vais dans la rue je peins je reprends
une autre photographie virtuel parce que
numérique et je le partage ensuite comme
j'avais partagé dans la rue je partage
sur internet et vous autres qui passent
et qui avait envie de prendre une photo
vous reprenez le poteau pour partager
sur internet et on passe ainsi au
virtuel du virtuel au réel
c'est un fait une boucle et c'est un
échantillonnage infinie il y à quelques
temps j'ai été démarché d'une manière un
petit peu originale par une entreprise
une très très grande entreprise par mail
qui m'a contacté pour t1 d'intervenir
dans un cadre en fait qu'ils étaient
tout à fait d'un nouveau pour moi il
s'agissait de réaliser des oeuvres pour
un jeu vidéo donc de réaliser des
dessins qu'ils puissent être intégrés
dans un mini reprises moi je la
connaissais seulement comme ça de non
parce que je ne joue pas aux jeux vidéo
je n'y joue plus depuis que j'ai voilà
depuis au moins 25 ans joue plus le
temps passe
et donc cette entreprise au départ je me
rendais pas compte en fait de
l'importance de la proposition qui me
faisaient c'est seulement autour de moi
quand j'ai dit vous savez ils m'ont
contacté parce que c'est pas n'importe
qui c'est le troisième plus gros
éditeurs de jeux vidéo au monde m'ont
contacté pour participer à un jeu vidéo
ou dans un univers virtuel je sais pas
trop ce qu'ils vont me demander
et là tout mon entourage s'est intéressé
aux jeux vidéo aux dîmes c'est énorme il
faut absolument que tu te rendes à ce
rendez vous donc je me suis rendu j'ai
été à leur siège qui se trouve à
montreuil dans une énorme tour j'ai
monté quelques étages part à ce penseur
seul je suis arrivé dans une grande
salle j'étais encore seul dans cette
salle et des écrans sont descendus il
s'agissait en fait d'un entretien par
visioconférence
donc je me suis installé mes
interlocuteurs me parlait en fait depuis
le canada
au prix ce qui est également une
entreprise française dont le siège est
en bretagne a également des bureaux et
toute une industrie
outre atlantique aux etats unis
essentiellement au canada et donc mes
interlocuteurs se trouvait au canada et
m'ont expliqué parce que j'avais
quelques a priori quand même je suis dit
qu'est ce qu'ils vont proposer est ce
qu'ils vont proposer de faire un jeu
vidéo de street art ou peut-être un jeu
vidéo les gens devraient faire du c215
ainsi qu'est ce qu'ils vont proposer
j'étais resté inquiet je vous avoue et
je me suis installé confortablement et
m'ont convaincu parce qu'ils m'ont
expliqué voilà monsieur camille on suit
votre travail depuis un moment
il s'agit en fait de vous proposer de
réaliser des oeuvres qui serait intégré
en tant que fresque dans un univers
architectural en trois dimensions d'un
village qui se trouverait en asie on
vous confie ray des visuels voulait
transformer y ait en oeuvre d'art et
nous les intégrerons dans le jeu
pourquoi vous parce que vous êtes
portraitiste parce que vous réalisez
donc des portraits d'humains mais aussi
d'animaux or les animaux une place toute
particulière dans le jeu parce que vous
manipulez la couleur avec quand même un
certain une certaine expérience
j'aime beaucoup les couleurs fortes et
vous avez beaucoup voyagé de par le
monde notamment dans l'est en asie
et là ils m'ont fait défiler des photos
des oeuvres que j'avais laissé derrière
moi à new delhi en inde en 2008 et m'ont
dit voilà pour ces quatre raisons vous
êtes l'artiste qu'on aimerait pouvoir
obtenir pour intégrer des fraises en jeu
dont on fête le scénario se passe en
asie dans un village s'applique à tout
pirate ou un dictateur local un
narcotrafiquant
ou un narcotrafiquant en fait aux primes
toute une population locale et le joueur
auquel enfin voilà le joueur vient dans
le jeu et parmi les choses qui doit
découvrir ou entreprendre dans le
village il peut il devra découvrir les
fresques que vous aurez laissé puisque
vous êtes supposé être passé dans le
village auparavant j'ai trouvé que
c'était un scénario qui me qui était
convaincant puisque ça vaut en aucun cas
une caricature de mon travail s'agissait
réellement de me faire réaliser dans le
virtuel
les choses que j'ai l'habitude de
réaliser dans le réel et la laventure
donc j'ai accepté c'était rémunérateurs
mais pas tant que ça c'était surtout une
expérience j'ai accepté et la démarche a
commencé entre nous ils m'ont demandé en
fait d'ouvrir une boîte en fait chez eux
sur leurs comptes sur leurs serveurs
avec des codes secrets chaque fois il me
qui me contacterait ils m'enverraient un
mail sur ma boîte personnelle pour
m'informer que j'avais un mail sur la
boîte secrète et là il fallait que je
m'empresse parce que souvent aussi les
documents et fait il avait il y avait un
délai très court pour les récupérer donc
fallait que je m'empresse d'aller
récupérer le document de données en fait
mes appréciations sur le visuel qui
m'était proposé et nous avions convenu
en fait que je réalise 16 oeuvre neuf
personnages et sept animaux à la base
qui devrait être intégré dans le jeu et
donc ont validé progressivement un par
un tous les personnages et les éléments
qui me proposait et j'ai réalisé donc un
travail assez classique à partir pour où
j'ai pu réaliser des animaux colorés
comme ils l'ont demandé là on voit ici
le personnage principal du jeu s'appelle
pas gamine sur lequel j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps
un animal comme celui ci j'ai passée est
quasi une semaine pour le réaliser
puisque tout est réalisé au pochoir et
en technique mixte
voilà des personnages
encore des personnages donc une manière
de travailler tout à fait être
additionnels pour moi puisque en fait ce
sont des photos que je découpe pour
créer des gabarits au travers duquel je
peins c'est la technique du pochoir tout
ce qui est plus traditionnel tout ce qui
est plus basique tout ce qui est plus
réel et au fur et à mesure que je
réalisais les oeuvres par mail bien sûr
je leur envoyais une première un premier
à une première vue sur l'oeuvre et je
dois avouer que même si j'avais la
priory travailler avec une équipe qui
est quand même
ce sont de grands professionnels du
design et du gaming je me suis dit
peut-être hilal est sourcilleux ou
qu'ils allaient avoir beaucoup
d'exigence ils ont été formidables ils
ont jamais vraiment ni la pression ni
sur la qualité ou à chaque fois c'était
des offres qui trouve à être qualitatif
donc j'en suis content ni sur la qualité
ni sur aucun autre domaine ils m'ont
embêté d'ailleurs je peux dire avec
étonnement je pense est tombé sur une
mécanique un petit peu froid des huiles
et il ya eu un moment parce que c'est
quand même un chantier qui a duré un an
et demi ils ont disparu pendant trois
mois puis de nouvelles je retournais
régulièrement sur ma boîte secrète
je me suis dit que ils appellent ça un
mandat cette édition dix commissions
chez les anglais une commande en
français au canada en dire mandat donc
je me tillie peut-être que j'ai perdu
mon mandat mais non ils étaient juste
occupé à tout un tas d'autres choses
parce que vous savez ces jeux vidéo
aujourd'hui c'est quasi c'est comme
l'industrie du cinéma ça ça mobilise des
équipes faramineuses aussi bien pour la
virtualité que la scénarisation tous les
éléments et les musiciens qui sont
attelés au jeu pour la bande originale
et serrant les dents des
superproductions ou dans lesquels mes
oeuvres ne sont qu'un tout petit élément
sinon un bonus pour les joueurs à
découvrir dans l'évolution du jeu donc
on a fait part j'ai fait parvenir un peu
tous les visuels les uns après les
autres ils ont tous été la veille en
fait de rendre le travail définitif tout
était si professionnellement menez qui
sont aperçus qu'il manquait une
illustration
donc j'ai travaillé en précipitations on
a envoyé tout ça je pensais que j'allais
rencontrer une équipe de photographes
nous cette entreprise on m'a envoyé un
photographe professionnel
si bien que les photos sont partis au
canada et j'ai rencontré personne
voilà comment ça s'est passé
or il ya deux mois maintenant on m'a
proposé de participer à une exposition à
la fondation edf sur l'innovation dans
le street art
évidemment je me suis dit ce serait
quand même le moment de présenter ce qui
a été fait entre cette entreprise et ma
petite activité artistique car je pense
qu'il s'agit d'un phénomène assez
innovant et donc on a sollicité en fait
cette entreprise pour qu'ils nous
envoient un peu en avance le résultat de
l'intégration de mes oeuvres dans leur
jeu puisque il était question est-ce
qu'ils intègrent eux mêmes les oeuvres
dans le jeu non pas comme moi je le
ferai dans la réalité mais pour que ça
prenne sens dans le jeu et dans les
différentes étapes du jeu et c'est ainsi
que j'ai pu découvrir comme vous le
découvrez la vidéo qui présente mes
oeuvres dans l'univers virtuel de cette
ville qui s'appelle qui rate dans lequel
les joueurs peuvent évoluer trucider à
foison se faire écraser par les
éléphants dévoré par des léopards
consommée par un tigre croiser des
personnages tous plus étonnants les uns
que les autres puisque moi je connais
pas encore réellement
ce jeu vidéo je n'y joue pas et je dois
bien vous avouer corps c'est pas
vraiment le type d'activité laquelle je
me livre mais je vais tout comme vous si
vous le souhaitez découvrir un peu ses
oeuvres dans cet univers prochainement
puisque jeu est sorti la semaine
dernière
il s'appelle far cry 4 et c'est je
remercie la société ubisoft de m'avoir
offert cette opportunité
ainsi j'ai pu repartir dans ma réalité
avec mes petits dessins sans jamais
avoir rencontré personne